what must go through the mind of a man
forced to start over at 71.
his life's work leveled in an instant by
a Russian rocket
watching his daughter sift through the
rubble where her mother died
I gripped my teeth I can't sleep at
night when I come here to the bomb site
I feel a bit better working doing things
at the site
very difficult for me very difficult
vasil and his wife were buried alive in
an attack in Sumi earlier this month he
made it out
she was crushed to death in the home
they'd built together
when explosions shatter the quiet of
Village Life the contrast is Stark
Yuri is the only police officer for a
community of 5 000 people his daily
roster the thing of nightmares
he says he used YouTube to teach himself
how to defuse bombs it's nice and
beautiful here and you see people going
about their day but we never know when
the selling Could Happen Russians use
all kinds of weapons tanks helicopters
mortars it's become routine for them
a school counselor says children and
adults are exhibiting stress responses
when the bombs stop falling communities
will need long-term help
we feel fear and anxiety everything
inside the body tenses up Palms become
sweaty the entire body Shivers it can
depend on where the shelling is
happening how close people are to the
explosions
on battlefields and front lines war is a
terrible thing to comprehend more so in
civilian areas
four staff members died at this school
in Romney attacked just days before the
end of summer break
it was deeply painful for everyone who
are all one big family here one team it
has psychologically ruined our mental
state
this near complete destruction was the
work of just one drone the people who
work here say they don't feel that it
was random they feel they were
deliberately targeted and there is
perhaps no softer a Target than a
children's School
though Moscow denies it targets
civilians for communities in Sumi far
from military targets the war feels
closer every day
bringing with it they say the terror of
knowing they might be next
Zane Bas Ravi Al Jazeera in Ukraine's
Northern Sumi region